é só você só os 23 feras aqui do canal
vão entender o pac escrito a palavra
pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que seja
muito bem vindo os canais um vídeo e
hoje trago vos aqui finalmente esta é
lindíssima caixa aí vêm comprar coisas
não escutei inúteis coisas que não vou
usar coisas que vou usar tudo pode estar
aqui nesta caixa até porque eu sou
viciado mesmo então eu gosto dos
produtos eu gosto deles funciona por lá
então quer dizer que dentro da caixa dão
isso eu tenha que muita coisa e não são
os produtos que eu comprei na black
friday eu quero porque ainda demora
cerca de dois meses cara ainda não
passaram dois meses então essas coisas
ainda estão para chegar portanto aqui
dentro estão coisas que eu nem strike no
canal encomendar hoje que vocês vão ver
isso aqui me peguem voz cafezinho
pessoal achem e de poder neste vídeo
magnífico como sabem sou ansioso vou ter
cuidado aqui para nos mostrar a minha
morada aberta olha isso tá bom enfim do
jec leão more lily eu não falei do que
isso parece uma caixa de um telemóvel
mas eu não encomendou um telemóvel
vamos ver o sorriso cafofo incrível
queremos é isso tá tudo muito bem bolado
hockey uma caixinha toda lançou latas
especial o já sei o que isso é
olha aí incrível incrível isso que eu
tenho aqui nas minhas mãos é um é
parelho algo equipo serve para
amplificação da senhora só quer provar
ao vivo eu sempre quis testar uma coisa
desta série
a vesticon isso muito mal e 16 isso
acontece só comigo está por ser rico mas
quando eu tiro só conseguiu isso mau tom
eu estou mal eu estou vivo serem existem
com pilha
agora que olha aí o caim no óleo
aumentaram 1 será que funciona já fui o
meu deus meu deus isso não modifica
muito a subir no crime claro nato já
cumpridas as coisas a pensar que não
funciona também muito burro né isto
assim não é lei o prefeito aqui em casa
mesmo bem lei não isso é incrível eu
ouvi na minha própria voz tinha um
volume muito alto eu consigo ver a mim
mesmo dentro dos meus ossos e permite
estranho ao o teste de som esta incrível
do sul do rio que estava no chamado de
idiota mas eu espero que dê tapas fiar
as pessoas que precisam estar estarei do
outro lado envolvido que é preciso estou
fazer é o alvo era 10 eu dou 10 produto
não funciona cumpra o que prometeu caiu
aumentar o bumbum da província muito bem
n treinamento para uma coisa assim na
china
tá muito ruim eo time italiano é
incrível olha só o próximo presidente
que nós temos aqui uma capinha para
chuva que tem um só é nossa equipe para
a chuva está aqui com certeza que não
foi mais do que um dólar a 2 o caio está
a dar muito jeito tá chovendo muito e
tenho ficado muito doente por campanha
chuva
olha aí o prefeito eu tô na moda eu não
apóio chuva em toda moda e que está
parecido do filme do ricms muita coisa
né ela o próximo produto aqui temos uma
imagem em preto uma coisa fininha banho
é vamos lançar um desafio pessoal de
portugal que cometi toda embaixo quer
ouvir o pessoal do brasil que comentei
machuque isopor vamos ver quantas
pessoas é que estamos aqui no canal só
há mais brasileiros a mais portuguesa de
portugal e também aqui dentro de uma
capa eu já sei o que é pessoal e que
entra aqui dentro nós temos um vinho
para o meu iphone o iphone 11 inclusive
também já do lado mas não é um livro
qualquer eu acho que eu posso chamar
este vídeo um vidro
peões porque eu já demonstrar agora
porque não segue no tic tóxico vou
deixar embaixo só deu o time está um
vídeo adam sigam tá incrível lá então
colar ea capa e vocês vão ver o que vai
acontecer disse vittorio eu sei por que
essa tela ser quando não estou a ver
frente vocês conseguem ver passaram
desde que o afasta o telemóvel pro lado
mesmo que eu quisesse ópera um ballo
visão completamente ou fica escuro fica
completamente escuro já ficou tudo preto
que vocês conseguem ver novo e e que
fica tudo preto outra vez
acredito que fiz minhas coisas
importantes e mandar os meus irmãos até
só que está do meu lado não vai
conseguir ver nada do que estou a fazer
porque ela está precisamente no ângulo e
inclui tela nova fica escuro meu iphone
meu tá completamente invisível e que já
perdi a visão total está cá é muito útil
se vocês forem desconfiados eles
quiserem fazer coisas em segredo não é
se quiserem que os machine que não vai
suas conversas assim ok seria desta
película eu do texto é um produto
incrível é barato do desp adorei andré
góes uma embalagem que chegou é você
quem é a responsabilidade se quer mas a
coisa está bem abertas só aquilo que nós
temos dentro eu acho que não seria justo
afinal não saiu só com praia quando as
pessoas estão paradas pela polícia na
estrada por suspeita de terem bebido
demais não é simplesmente para
realizarem test infelizmente há muita
gente que bebe álcool e vai conduzir meu
ser e eu sei que a maioria das pessoas
falam que nesse canal são norte entre os
12 e os 16 anos e os serviços mas também
tem muita gente luta com a companhia que
já conduz portanto eu deixo aqui o meu
concelho pessoal não bebam se vão
conduzir simples e evitou amor fácil
prático e simples não bebo e isso é um
dos dispositivos para medir esse mesmo
seus para aqui dentro nós vamos
conseguir ver se eu entendi o álcool no
sangue ou não um podem ver só ela sendo
e possui um painel com 10 segundos e nós
temos esses destes mundos para superar
aquele no qual há dois mil anos depois
ok vamos ver quanto álcool no sangue
jô olha aí 20 a cair não vou dar uma
lição esse produto porque eu preciso ver
se funciona realmente eu tinha ido
dormir álcool e costinha fazer o teste
para ver se eu conseguir essa álcool mas
eu não vou fazer isso agora o pimento
estou gravado nem quero ver se quer
então elevou a avaliação porque pode
funcionar muito bem o simplesmente pode
não funcionar então vamos deixar de lado
e já sabem pessoal se vocês têm idade
para conduzir já conduzem não bebo ok
mas uma embalagem quilos possa mostrar e
memorável cair e rubrique baixo o que
nós temos aqui o pessoal está incrível
funcionar mil euros o caio morel
sprinklers projetava isso ou seja são
brinquedos que terão coisas não é então
vamos ver se funciona ou não assim ser
perigoso
ok eu só comentei protestar cair quase
que me então organismo ele tem um
lançador e depois nós temos
procedimentos tenta colocar isso pode
ser perigoso porque são beneficiadas mas
não está em cachorro agora é só clicar
aqui nesse botão e supostamente
disparado vamos ver se funciona bola 321
ró to gather é seok caixa incrível estar
aqui a 321 roupa sua caixa agora possui
aqui só se quiserem que eu faça um vídeo
de estar aqui esta ferramenta cometem
mas também posso fazer meu mas não
brinquei com essas coisas
apesar de ser um brinquedo pode acabar
por ser perigoso até portanto tenho
muito cuidado quando em menos tempo
coisas não brinquei sozinhos com isso
porque se podem agora os mesmos então
brinca com os nossos pais locais bom mas
funciona nesta talvez um outro né enfim
vem aqui o trinco mendonça e volta para
quem morada que nós temos aqui com a ok
ok cunhas postiças
minas biquíni como é que vocês conseguem
explicar como é que vocês conseguem dar
assine todo 1 da qual é a próxima coisa
que nós temos aqui uma embalagem gigante
vamos lá abre o carioca mais uma caixa
de papelão eo e pop girls é esse
concluiu sesap público só aqui dentro
nós temos o famosinho eu não sei como é
que estes dizem português a dentadura
dia mas é isso
enfim não olha aí equipe que a dentadura
do diamante dos rappers da atualidade
olha só que aí como é que se use isso
vamos ver aqui tomar as instruções só
cairão com o cara com uma pinça dentro
d'água quinto com um toque bem aqui com
essas duas gotinhas que eu vou colocar
aqui dentro
depois é só deixar na água quente né
porque depois do toque é como se uma
cola quente e eu possa agarrar os dentes
mas eu não vou fazer isso eu acho eu
acho que não vou fazer já estão vou
guardar esse bruto conteúdo eu acho a
isso agora ninguém tinha médico
só quero fazê las o comitê embaixo
fenece pode fundar 18 este produto eu
não tenho na totalidade eu não esteja
100% ok tem qualidade é sol e obviamente
que seria amante de fautré uma lógica da
wishes deve ter sido bem barato bom mas
serve o propósito eu acho que dá pra
fazer um cosplay assim selado eo pão por
isso assumirá a versão 8 que nós temos
aqui uma embalagem gigante foi isso que
inclusive já está aberta uma tal
é do juiz xii bombas e que nós temos
aqui o 1 já não lembro o capitólio como
é que uma franquia é um bichinho se ele
sem dar chances criadas e 15 milhões
para fazer loucuras estarão unidos é de
uma simplicidade está no escuro tempo
vai ficar processo mas eu não sei por
que inclui dois o jovem armado o que
quero saber como é que funcionam pessoal
colocar assim pra macho tem aqui o
temporizador
acho que sou da corda ok
[Música]
o google instant falou comigo sobre isso
porque é gol ontem como leite maio/11
recordem não tem que estar sempre de ok
eu acho que deixou 18 7
não não é tão grande
cada um dois três quatro cinco toques rr
é basicamente a saltar à corda esconder
e ea pessoa que passar ao lado vai estar
porque é impossível nosso estado com
isso não é esse tempo que condenava a
cair mexe eu vou dar certo vou dar um cd
só porque está mesmo até o teatro
esperando absurdo então isso é incrível
o meu quem não tá super baixos com
certeza eu sai muito rápido
olha aí sim depois o irmão [ __ ]
nós temos aqui queijo óculos é este que
os produtos frios e só pagam o esporte
eu ainda estou para fazer um vídeo só
com produtos frio que é auguste los
o outro furto do mesmo bush que é
incrível o movimento da acção a
cosmética cristo derramado que sim eu
sair mas a óculos que tem uma lei
específica que depois não é que o país
vem aqui é literalmente o que eu estou
vendo também vai financiar junto consigo
explicar até mexer vermelha ainda está
mais informada mileu só acho que é um
fica fashion
eu acho que quem criou o pêndulo isso
vai se quebrar em que uma semana talvez
portanto qualquer um
o méxico é o segundo mais coisas e essa
é a última coisa eu tenho tempo para que
tudo esteja morar em todos os vídeos não
faz idéia do que isto é aquilo que falei
da última encomenda prefiro que isto é
não faz idéia de um monte de fios longos
cabos aquilo que quero ou média time pro
pccv que manual de instruções
chan luiz fux connecting de filmes em
dvd e na hydro girl band método serve
para insista que só você já tem isso
nunca que eu disser aqui em casa é bom
temos aqui então são vários cabos de
cobre rock uma ponta a síndica escala eu
não sei se eu posso dizer de pescado por
isso não é uma fruta as nossas também né
isso além de comunicação é isso aí eu
falei vocês perceberem a aí que vocês
têm uma ponta que tem uma resistência
com 18 arno igniter que os jogos vão
mostrar e vocês a distância e conseguem
ascender exclusivos ou ocella uma
bombinha ou por uma vela sei lá tudo o
que eu preciso ignited isso faz a
distância e vamos mostrar agora até isso
é descartável por isso é feito de 50
espécies u$1 também então o que nós
temos aqui um dispositivo de controle
remoto que inclusive já tem pilhas por
objetivo colocar aqui ok nós temos
também o comando que o clube o
dispositivo à distância como é que isso
funciona vocês têm aqui o negativo eo
positivo é só colocar uns então aqui os
dois pedaços de cobre e que esta planta
vocês têm uma menina resistência que eu
não sei se vocês vão conseguir ver mas
está lá e ganhar aqui nesse botão eu vou
dar um sinal para o igk na itália
ignazio vai aquecer o cobre eo quadro
vai aquecer a ministros e tem aqui é
impossível não sei como é que eu posso
fazer isto me magoaram quer só tem aqui
um mini firecracker o que é isso nada
mais é só exclusivos de sonda e não é
perigoso tanto nós vamos fazer com que o
teste só para a instituição aqui
inclusive eu vou mostrar que não quer
parar aqui ok
a sola em 3
[Música]
eu eu ou o funcionário ok ok ok só você
sabe o que quer dizer não é isto quer
dizer que eu consigo explodir o
exclusivo dentro do quarto pincela estar
dentro a distância o símbolo da incrível
aqui eu acho que existem se queimou ou
não ainda posso usar outra vez só pra
vocês verem como como funciona o a321
que está acendeu agora sim não ainda
posso usar outra vez
ok mais uma vez mais um trailer na agora
já queimou ok meu deus a torna esse
dispositivo é agora está incrível
inclusive também que o país não isso eu
consegui encontrar e deixar aqui o preço
eu vou deixar mas é só para fazer com
que o craque dos filhos já sabe quanto
com voz meg whitman em processos
químicos no adap espírito pms ou link
empregos que não liga nada cair somente
para que vocês tenham gostado se
quiserem mais coisas não esquentem
também se comprar um produto de santo
possuem também um link que eu vou ver
posso comprar entrar aqui no canal e só
espero que em um estado fica em média
até a próxima